Un mito arraigado dice que usamos
solo el 10 % del cerebro.
Y el otro 90 % queda
con capacidad ociosa.
Los mercachifles prometían
liberar el potencial oculto
&quot;con base en la neurociencia&quot;,
pero solo abrieron
nuestras billeteras.
Dos tercios del público
y casi la mitad de los
profesores de ciencias
creen erróneamente
en el mito del 10 %.
En los años 1890, William James,
el padre de la
psicología estadounidense,
dijo: "La mayoría no usa todo
el potencial de la mente".
James pensó esto como un desafío,
no como una acusación del uso
restringido del cerebro.
Pero quedó el malentendido.
Además, los científicos no entendieron
durante mucho tiempo
el propósito del abultado
lóbulo frontal
o de las amplias zonas
del lóbulo parietal.
Si se dañaban no había
déficits motores o sensoriales
por eso concluyeron
que no eran de utilidad.
Durante décadas estas partes
se denominaron zonas silenciosas
y su función era desconocida.
Luego aprendimos que
cumplen funciones
ejecutivas y de integración,
sin las cuales apenas
seríamos humanos.
Son cruciales para el
razonamiento abstracto,
la planificación,
para sopesar decisiones
y adaptarnos en forma flexible
a las circunstancias.
La idea de que 9/10 del cerebro
están ociosos en el cráneo
parece una tontería al calcular
el uso de energía del cerebro.
Los cerebros de roedores
y caninos consumen
el 5 % de la energía
total del cuerpo.
El cerebro de los monos
usa el 10 %.
El cerebro de un humano adulto
que representa solo el 2 %
de su masa corporal,
consume el 20 % de la
glucosa diaria consumida.
En los niños, esa cifra es el 50 %;
y en los infantes, el 60 %.
Esto es mucho más de lo esperado
para sus tamaños cerebrales relativos
que aumentan en proporción
al tamaño corporal.
Los de humanos pesan 1,5 kilos,
los de elefante, 5 kg,
y los de ballena, 9 kg.
Incluso por gramaje,
los humanos condensan más neuronas
que cualquier otra especie.
Esta densidad es la que
nos hace tan inteligentes.
Hay una relación de compromiso
entre el tamaño del cuerpo
y la cantidad de neuronas
que un primate
—incluidos nosotros—
puede sostener.
Un simio de 25 kg tiene
que comer 8 horas al día
para mantener un cerebro con
53 000 millones de neuronas.
La invención de la cocina,
hace un millón y medio de años,
nos dio una gran ventaja.
Los alimentos cocinados
se suavizan y predigieren
fuera del cuerpo.
Nuestros intestinos absorben
más fácilmente su energía.
Cocinar libera tiempo
y nos da más energía
que comer alimentos crudos;
por eso podemos sostener cerebros
con 86 000 millones de neuronas,
40 % más que los simios.
Funciona así:
la mitad de las calorías
quemadas por el cerebro
va simplemente a mantener
intacta la estructura
bombeando iones de sodio y potasio
a través de las membranas para
mantener una carga eléctrica.
Para hacerlo, el cerebro tiene
que ser un cerdo de la energía.
Consume 3,4 x 10^21 moléculas
de ATP por minuto,
siendo el ATP el carbón
del horno corporal.
El alto costo de mantenimiento
de potenciales de reposo
en los 86 000 millones de neuronas
significa que queda poca energía
para impulsar señales por
los axones y las sinapsis,
las descargas en los nervios
que realmente hacen las cosas.
Incluso si solo un pequeño
porcentaje de las neuronas
disparara en una región dada
en un momento dado,
la energía necesaria para activar
todo el cerebro
no sería sustentable.
Aquí entra en juego
la eficiencia energética.
Dejar que solo una
pequeña porción de células
se active en determinado momento
se conoce como "codificación escasa";
usa la menor cantidad de energía
pero transmite la mayor
cantidad de información.
Porque la pequeña cantidad de señales
tiene miles de caminos posibles
por los que distribuirse.
Un inconveniente de
la codificación escasa
dentro de una enorme
cantidad de neuronas
es su costo.
Peor aún, si una gran proporción
de células nunca se disparan,
entonces son superfluas
y la evolución debería haberlas
desechado hace mucho tiempo.
La solución es encontrar
la proporción óptima de células
que el cerebro puede
activar al mismo tiempo.
Para eficiencia máxima,
entre el 1 % y el 16 % de las células
deberían estar activas al mismo tiempo.
Este es el límite energético
con el que tenemos que vivir
para mantener la conciencia.
La necesidad de conservar recursos
es la razón por la que la mayoría
de las operaciones del cerebro
debe ocurrir fuera del estado consciente.
Por eso que la multitarea es una tontería.
Sencillamente no tenemos la energía
para hacer 2 cosas a la vez
y ni hablar 3 o 5.
Al intentarlo,
hacemos peor cada tarea
que si le hubiéramos
prestado toda la atención.
Los números no son favorables.
El cerebro ya es inteligente y potente.
Tan potente que necesita mucha potencia
para mantenerse potente.
Y tan inteligente
que ha construido un plan
de eficiencia energética.
No permitan que un mito fraudulento
les haga sentir culpa de
cerebros supuestamente perezosos.
La culpa sería un desperdicio de energía.
Después de todo esto,
¿no creen que es tonto desperdiciar
energía mental?
Tienen miles de millones
de neuronas con hambre
de energía que mantener.
¡En marcha!